We would now like to discuss
drag forces in a fluid.
Now remember that fluids
can be both a liquid or air.
And drag forces are
actually quite complicated
depending on a lot of factors.
If we had an object
falling in a fluid,
the drag forces can depend
on both the properties
of the object--
and in that case,
it might be the
speed or the size
or the shape of the
object-- and it also
can depend on the
properties of the fluid.
It can depend on the
density of the fluid.
It can depend on a
property that measures
the resistance of
a fluid, something
which we'll refer
to as viscosity,
and also a property about the
compressibility of a fluid.
So in general, this
is quite complicated.
And this is done empirically.
There's a few very special
cases that we'll discuss
that can be solved exactly.
Now let's begin our
modeling by considering
what we call air drag.
Now in air drag, objects
that are moving--
and we'll consider objects
that are moving rapidly.
So our objects are
moving very fast.
Now in that case, we can
model-- make a rough model
of the air drag as follows.
The magnitude of
this force is going
to be proportional
to the speed squared.
There'll be a factor where
it's the cross-sectional area
that the object presents in
the motion, perpendicular
to the plane of motion.
It can depend on the
density of the air.
And traditionally there are a
couple of coefficients in here
that are dimensionless that
are empirically determined
by the shape of the object.
And that's called
the drag coefficient.
And in fact, there's also
a factor 1/2 in the way
this law is
traditionally written.
So what we have here is
a resistive force which
is proportional to the
speed squared and depends
on the properties of the
air, the density of the air,
and some physical parameters--
properties of the object
itself.
Now this drag coefficient--
we can have a table that
can represent that.
And you can see here that for
a variety of different shapes,
the drag coefficient is
somewhere on the order of 1.
So this is an example of
what we refer to as air drag.
When we drop objects in a
fluid at very slow speeds,
we have a different effect than
what we talked about air drag.
For example, if we drop
a marble in molasses
and drop the same
marble in water,
we see a very different motion.
And that depends on a
property of the fluid which
we'll refer to as viscosity.
Now we'll denote a
coefficient of viscosity
by the symbol n, eta.
Now when we drop an
object in a fluid,
that the drag force in
magnitude will be proportional
to both viscosity-- will be
proportional to the speed
and it will be proportional
to the viscosity.
And now, for various
special cases,
so for the special case which
is a sphere of radius r,
if you study fluid dynamics,
we can get an exact solution
for this drag force.
And we'll describe
that as-- it's
going to be opposite the
direction of the velocity,
so there's a minus sign.
There turns out to be
some coefficients-- 6 pi
times the viscosity of the fluid
times the radius of the sphere.
And this particular law, which
we'll known as Stokes' law,
is exactly applicable to
the motion of a sphere.
Now in fact, by
experimental measurement,
this is a method for
determining eta experimentally
by dropping objects-- spheres--
in various different media
with different viscosities.
So we can use this to
experimentally determine
the viscosity of the medium.
And what's important
to realize, too,
is that this is applicable
to many different examples.